the route seems even longer if your legs
are short braving freezing temperatures
these refugees have reached Macedonia
the first stage of the Western Balkan
route they're driven on by the fear that
borders along the route could close down
ahead of them and they're more than glad
to leave Greece behind in a camp it was
really bad there is no good food no warm
place they just told us there is some
light these houses you can't go in it
but there is no heat 48 hours we spent
that and they gave us some paper that to
let us to go into Europe but only those
who are from Iraq Syria or Afghanistan
are allowed into the country all the
other silent seekers are facing a
brand-new fence provided by Hungary some
still managed to cross it by night such
as these two young men from Libya they
have been stranded in Macedonia for over
thirty days now crossing the country by
foot only to get stuck at the border to
Serbia when armed a year friend of mine
tried going through the woods but he got
picked up by the police
Sameer from Aleppo in Syria has better
luck for 25 euros authorities offered
him transport by train to the Serbian
border his ultimate goal is to reach
Germany that is the final destination
written on a piece of paper he received
in Greece a document that will also get
him across these improvised checkpoints
into Serbia some people they have paper
not good yeah they make it they pay
money for bad man they make it and they
come somebody they catch somebody
somebody they don't catch
Macedonia is a multi-ethnic state
blighted by corruption and other serious
domestic problems nevertheless some
politicians in the capital scope here
find the idea of turning the country
into a firewall against migrants from
Greece potentially appealing the poor
country striving to become a member of
the EU could soon become a frontline
state in the Ministry of the Interior
Anastasia I Jessica says her government
is considering plans to close the border
to Greece entirely if the EU wanted that
we asked cover of cost of European Union
because for our budget like Republic of
Macedonia it's very hard to manage all
cost who are produced this crisis
critics such as eight worker Jasmine
recipe one however that closing borders
could lead to a humanitarian crisis
moreover it would only divert Micron's
he says and revive all people smuggling
networks already last year his
organization unveiled a number of people
smuggler camps there were people in in
the houses in one house 100 illegal
migrants were held in hostage and
meeting every day just to make them
pressure their family to give the money
for the smuggler so they can transfer
them to Serbia just as in Macedonia the
transport of these migrants coming from
Syria Iraq and Afghanistan has been well
organized by the Serbian authorities at
this reception center in Brazil they
have to show their Greek documents and
pass through a cursory security check
many people doctors here say refused to
stay overnight including one very weak
pregnant woman eventually they made a
decision to continue they gave us the
reason they were very open and sincere
about it they they are moving in groups
in big groups the family mainly they are
moving big groups it means that they are
getting support from their small
community
beg let the Macedonian border with
Greece more large groups like these have
arrived and everyone is desperate for a
new pair of shoes shoes fit for the
European winter and for the onward
journey to the next border on the
Western Balkan route